hello everybody ah shut up
hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play amnesia Justine okay I just
found something I can put slides in here
but I don't do anything so I'm guessing
I gotta pull that lever or I'm hoping
maybe I have the wrong combination and
it's like I don't know I haven't
brute-force this there are four times
three times
no there I don't know how many
permutations there are I think four
times three times two I don't know I
don't know four and one I don't know I'm
think I'm right I think I'm right with
the clues here I think it's I think it's
you know the right one the the two that
are facing the same direction and you
know you know because it said always
chooses to the puzzle like this must be
the puzzle Locke tends to choose two
slides with characters facing the same
way and she never picks the one with the
sword
so never pick the one with the sword so
here goes yeah yeah I get it
Oh what did i do what did I do gimme
gimme ha ha ha ha ha ha ha look out for
Justine oh I'm going to get her oh yeah
right I'm so smart okay
what did that do I'm gonna open this
door I don't know hello open up now what
get out here yeah here buddy
umm I don't know I don't know oh oh
secret bookshelf always behind the
secret bookshelf oh yeah okay come here
come here come here
oh yeah nope oho that's who it was I
saved him yeah
yeah probably not but I still saved him
he's not dead
Oh me and him are gonna team up and beat
you down uh-huh yeah whatever whatever
man
okay what do we got do I have any oil I
don't have any uh no ha ha get a
potatoes potatoes save me potatoes save
me potatoes ha ah there's some intense
music I hear anyone anymore
shut up oh shut up go away ah the
potatoes get two potatoes don't look at
me go over there go over there make
sound over there what do I do
so dark I can't see a damn thing Oh Oh
get out of here
Oh torch please torch please oh that's
no light at all I can't see a thing oh
is that what I think it is I think it is
chair Oh save me chair save me
oh man that musics even worse
oh sorry for this is my earliest thing
I've ever done
oh oh man he's right there oh it wasn't
even a chase scene really is he was just
there coming at me slowly something is
slowly coming this way no they are not
yeah whatever yeah for you oh yeah
Denise oh no not the water party not a
water party
inaudible hundred another water
oh no no water monsters no water
Oh like water parts I don't like water I
don't like water
you know like water it's locked of
course it's like oh why wouldn't it be
locked I don't like water I don't like
water I don't like water water bad yo Oh
um oh Leopard thank you yet lever hop
yeah it's definitely a girl playing
where's like playing on the whole shell
versus GLaDOS thing like she's GLaDOS
and I'm chill it's probably good yeah I
hear the box okay got a lever unknown
found you miss your flow hair my name is
Daniel Daniel you murdering bastard this
is the same time then Herbert
yeah Algeria yeah oh wow as I come to
understand you were among his most
trusted friends oh you're a real
predicament
okay lost contact a stone orb okay this
is one Daniel was reaching out for help
okay
ah I like it I like it okay um that was
something okay
um I got a lever I can do something with
it that other door was locked so I'm
guessing ah yeah stick it in here then I
can go on what huh
what close that in here or out there oh
oh
pwned you ha ha ha
done dented chance not even a little bit
cars still no lantern oil okay boo
oh don't even try it guy oh come on oh
yeah what do we got what do we got
come here come here
oh okay
I got I'll put a cogwheel on the thing
cuz everything's broken huh oh you
better do the who you get out of here
how can you even do it you're so scrawny
ah did he break through laughs no no no
no no no no okay okay okay I got it
what's in here okay good what is this
buddy
who are you who are you who are you I
don't know I don't know I don't know
what do i do what do i do what do i do I
don't know I don't know Oh monkey
oh good go boxes leap jump epic ah oh oh
oh I was supposed to ah damn it I was
supposed to save that guy oh I messed up
oh I messed up bad okay um
he died valiantly to save me of course
there were all those wheels on the but I
wouldn't have had time anyway
Oh to die he'd he died to save me he's
just that good of a bro maybe
well alright oh come on true dad laws
are oppressed oh whatever is this I
would have saved him oh this doesn't
look good uh-huh ah bodies disappearing
look you can't see a bloody thing um
there's a big room it's down here ha oh
it's see the lovely lady statue hello oh
sorry I just groped you there what was
mother like she was the most beautiful
creature ever to grace this world I
can't remember what she looked like
no matter how hard I try her beauty was
blinding Justina
ruff we could never dare to turn obtain
such memory to our mind it would be too
much to bear yeah I'm guessing that was
her and her dad I'm guessing this is a
statue of her mom
Oh yo mama's so fired kind of weird you
know for supplies but whatever is this
statute can't move here we go okay
graves lots of graves
alright then nothing here hello Oh
creepy drawings creepy drugs gimme gimme
best uh-huh I did awesome yeah yeah not
quite because you sent a monster ever
yeah my true nature is awesomeness
uh-huh he brought killed him oh you did
kill them yeah yeah you murdered it then
so much murdering chilies yep yep you
did yep
very poetic yeah yeah he's probably
buried out there he was probably that
corpse it disappeared oh boy okay anyway
I gotta cut it here thank you guys so
much for watching I hope you enjoy my
screams of Terror but anyway I will see
you in the next part
bye bye